so probably the main thing you will hear
when you talk about investing is what is
the return that you got on your
investment and return on investment is
oftentimes people will say Roi and
there's a lot of different ways of
calculating it but maybe the most basic
way is think about if you put a hundred
dollars into an investment this year and
then next year you got back a hundred
and ten dollars so you got a ten dollar
return on top of your hundred dollars
that you invested people would say that
you got a ten percent annual Roi or 10
return on investment annually now it can
get more complicated depending on what
type of an investment it is and how it
pays you out over time Etc but Roi is a
really good thing to think about any
investment you make generally speaking
you might say all right if there's one
thing that gives me a 20 Roi or return
investment that's better than something
that gives me a 10 Roi and if in terms
of risk they are similar the same then
that might very well be the case but it
turns out that there's usually a
trade-off between risk and return you're
usually not going to get a higher return
for something that is equally as risky
if that were the case everyone would
invest in that thing and not the thing
that's giving the lower return and so to
just give an example of how you see that
in the real world you can think of very
very very safe Investments for example
if you just have your money in a savings
or checking account you might get low
single digits one two three percent on
your money depending on where interest
rates are which doesn't feel like a lot
but it's very very very safe if it's
less than two hundred fifty thousand
dollars per person per account type well
then you are pretty much guaranteed to
get your money back so low risk and
arguably low return if you were to go
slightly higher risk you could do
something like lend to the federal
government you lend to the federal
government by buying treasury bonds and
treasury bills oftentimes T bills for
short
now those are pretty much guaranteed to
pay you what they say they're going to
pay you so you say okay why do I get
slightly higher interest for that than I
get on my checking account well it's a
little bit less convenient if you need
your money right that second yes you
could sell those treasury bills or
treasury bonds but those prices do
fluctuate so you're only guaranteed to
get the money plus the interest if you
hold it all the way all the way to
however long that treasury bond or
treasury bill was for it might be for
one year two years or ten years or
whatever it is and so there's a certain
risk not just for the price fluctuations
but also how accessible is that money
for example in that checking your
savings account if you want that money
you can usually get it within a business
within a working day usually in a matter
of hours if you have a treasury bond or
treasury bill it's a little bit more
complicated and you're going to have
more of those price fluctuations now if
you wanted to go up the risk and return
ladder a little bit more well you could
led to other entities you could lead to
Big safe companies they will pay you
higher interest than the federal
government will but there's a little bit
more risk that they might not pay that
loan back maybe they go out of business
maybe something dramatically negative
happens to their business and what
you'll generally see is you go to rescue
or sorry if you go to riskier and
riskier companies they're going to pay
higher and higher interest on their
bonds and if you look at the stock
market where you're actually buying a
share when you buy a stock what you're
buying a piece of the company you'll
normally see that the companies that
feel pretty risky they you might feel
like they could have a higher earn but
they could also have a much higher loss
as well while companies that are safer
in generally speaking you would expect
to have lower risk and also lower return
so it's important to think about return
on investment when you make an
investment and it's very very very very
very important to think about risk I
can't stress this enough how many people
have explained they're like oh I have a
guaranteed Roi investment I'm like okay
someone's lying to you because if it was
30 Roi guaranteed you would have all of
the major investment funds in the world
just investing in that why would they
let little old Sal invest or you Uncle
why would they let you invest in that if
it was really 30 guaranteed I would be
very skeptical of people who say
something like that there's usually a
risk that that person isn't um thinking
about or that return is in some way
Shady or fabricated which also makes me
feel that that whole proposition is even
riskier so you could there are
definitely ways that you can get 10 20
30 return but it's usually associated
with a decent dose of risk and when you
go into something like that also think
about the worst case scenario it's
either easy to dream about making all
the money but think about what would
happen if you lost 30 or 50 or 80 of
your money
how would you feel then and then
invest accordingly